-You know our first guest
tonight from films
such as "Big Daddy,"
"Happy Gilmore," "Uncut Gems,"
and of course his time on "SNL."
He co-wrote and stars
in "Hubie Halloween,"
which is currently streaming
on Netflix.
Please welcome back to the sho
one of our favorites,
Adam Sandler.
How are you, Adam?
-Seth!
Seth, that was to funny, man
I came in halfway through
with the pipe.
Was it Bing Crosby?
-It was a little Bing Crosby
It was a little Bing --
I tried to channel Bing Man.
-It was so funny, man!
It was great!
-Thank you so much!
I'm enjoying the beard.
Now a lot of people have
quarantine beards,
but this is actually -- this
is actually for a role,
correct?
-Yeah.
It started off
as a quarantine thing
and then it made sense
for the character,
and then I have it
and it's terrible.
I, uh...
I don't know what to do.
It doesn't feel good.
I just did a scene
with Queen Latifah
and she actually held it
and kept looking me
in the eyes while holding it
And then when they called cut,
I saw her face was kind of like,
"Whoa, that was rough."
[ Laughter ]
-You have two daughters.
How do they feel?
I'm always fascinated by
a kid's feedback
on things like facial hair
-I got my kid here.
Sunny, come here.
Say hi to Seth.
Say hi. See, that's Sunny.
-Hi.
-Hi, Sunny. How are you?
-Good. How are you?
-Good. How do you feel about
the beard, Sunny?
-Tell him.
What do think.
-I don't like it.
-You don't or you do?
-It shows your gray hairs.
-Oh, yeah, it's the only place
the grays are coming.
[ Laughter ]
-It usually -- it foreshadow
what the rest of the head'
gonna look like one day.
-By the way, I have a scar
on my hand,
but it's for the movie.
So this didn't happen to me.
But -- but --
-So nobody should be concerned
-I don't want you to be nervou
for me.
Anybody out there,
all of the nice people.
-Sunny, you're so good
in the movie.
Did you enjoy your time?
-Yes. Thank you.
[ Laughs ]
-Yes.
-It was really fun.
-We had a good time.
Her and her sister had fun
coming by the set being goof
and then running back
to their friends.
But do you know Seth's fro
New Hampshire, dude?
-Oh, you are?
-Yeah.
I grew up in Bedford,
which is the --
a slightly nicer town
than your dad is from.
-He's got more money --
-Did you guys know each othe
when you little?
-I raised him.
I was a babysitter for him
[ Laughter ]
I taught him --
I taught him how to be funny
when he was a little boy.
-He would come back
and do a program,
it was like a summer camp
where he would come back
and take kids who showed promise
in comedy
and would just take us
out to the woods.
-Yes, sir. Yes, sir.
I really got Seth going.
Sarah Silverman didn't
listen enough.
All right, I love you.
Get out of here.
Tell Seth thanks.
Mwah, I love you.
Okay, go, go.
-Bye. Thank you!
-Bye!
Nice to meet you.
-Yeah, she's nice, man.
Her and her sister
are very nice.
-That's good.
You got two nice kids.
-Yeah, yeah, you do too, right
You have two or one?
-I have two nice boys.
But I actually --
I was thinking while
I watching this movie becaus
your character Hubie is --
has multi-generations of peopl
in his hometown
have bullied him.
-Yes.
-And I think it's
a very valuable --
it must be nice to have
your kids on set
because the message is of course
to be nice to people.
-You know what's funny.
My two kids, they are so
anti-bullying.
Their generation is growing up
calling each other on like
"That's not nice.
You can't do that! You're mean
Don't say that."
It's pretty awesome.
Whereas, our New Hampshire
upbringing was
full attack at all times.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. I feel like
when we lived through
a New England upbringing,
it was a real trial by fire.
-[ Laughs ]
We got our comedy chops from
that neighborhood, man.
And -- but yes, it is --
Hubie does get picked
on a little bit too much,
and thank God, things
are gonna be okay for him
at the end of the day
but, wow, he really --
he's good at ignoring the pain
He's very good at that.
-This is a Halloween film.
Did you -- had you
long wanted to do
a Halloween film like this
-You know, Seth, I did
"Eight Crazy Nights"
for Hanukkah.
That was maybe 15 years ago.
So I was allowed
my Hanukkah movie.
I don't really know what other
holiday they'd let me make
Halloween, I've been celebrating
my entire life
and had the best time ever
with it.
So Netflix was like,
"Could you do a --
Could you do some sort
of a --"
What's that called again?
A -- What's Halloween again?
-A holiday?
-Oh, yeah, a holiday!
[ Laughter ]
That is right, man!
That was a dumb one
for the set!
I wouldn't really --
that lets you know
I haven't been sleeping much
But, yes, they wanted to d
a holiday movie
and I figured old Halloween,
I'm allowed to do that one
-That was a -- you put me
in a real weird situation ther
because I couldn't --
I thought I knew the word
you were looking for, but
kind of couldn't believe
it was the word
you couldn't find!
[ Laughter ]
-I'm really disgusting
with myself right now,
and in front of my kid
who is staring at me.
She's like,
"That's a baby word.
What don't you know
right now?"
I'm sorry about humiliatin
the whole family on that.
-I don't know if you
knew this about me,
because watching the movie
which takes place in Salem
my mom grew up in Marblehead
-See, that's incredible!
-Crazy, right?
-Yeah. That -- we lived ther
the whole time.
We shot a lot there.
And what a town.
-It's amazing.
-I didn't want to leave there.
It's the most beautiful wate
and the people are great.
We get to know --
and they, like, they --
the supermarkets we shot i
and there was ice cream
every day for everybody.
And man, that town.
Did you used to go there a lot
growing up, Seth?
-Yeah, we went there
all the time.
My grandmother lived
right by Abbott Hall,
right in the sort of center of
town there and --
-That town,
it's so beautiful there.
-Gorgeous.
-So you used to walk aroun
there as a kid.
Would you ride bikes there
and stuff?
-We -- I think we --
we rode some bikes.
We walked around a little bi
more 'cause I don't think
we'd bring our bikes.
But we --
You know, I saw it in the movi
and I had a real flashback
You have a scene
in the Salem Witch Museum.
-Yes, yes.
-And we used to go there
and that plays scared
the bejeesus out of me.
-Of course.
That scared me as an adult
It made me tense.
And my kids didn't --
We shot a scene for a day there,
and everybody was like, "Could
you please turn the music off?
They'd get scared in there
But everybody in Salem
and in Marblehead
and everywhere we shot
in Massachusetts,
they were so happy,
the people,
they were great to us and also
we brought Halloween with us
in the summertime,
so there was --
all over the town was
decorations and stuff
and it was a lot hotter than
it usually is during Halloween
but it was just really nice,
and nice memories we had.
Halloween's the best holiday
for sure.
It's just guaranteed happiness
and I wish it never went away.
I hate when November shows u
and you're like,
"We are done with that one
God!"
-Yeah, true.
'Cause there is a lot more -
'cause I feel like you don't
have any, like, family drama
with Halloween,
whereas like all of a sudden
then you go into Thanksgivin
and Christmas and Hanukkah
and it's all family.
-They kind of let you
on your own, families go.
"Yeah, you do your Halloween
and then we will destroy you
at Thanksgiving."
-I want to talk more about
the movie,
but we'll be right back
with more from Adam Sandler.